Have you thought about what you will be like after 10 years?
Let me picture that for you,...
...I guess you will have a professional career,...
...and will be getting ready to get married.
What do you think?
Correct me, if I'm wrong,...
...I guess this is the time to think about what you will do to make your dreams come true.
In my case, I had prepared before I graduated,...
...so, by the time I graduated, I already had a job.
I've been in this industry since then,...
...so after 10 years, I guess I will be in a different field making my living.
Also, I will have a happy family with two kids.
I wish, after 10 years, to have a professional and steady career.
I plan to get married after turning 35, or later,...
...so I can't tell whether I will be married by that time or not.
But hopefully, I have a date - mate.
And in 10 years from now, I will have my own house in the middle of an urban area,...
...my own car,...
...and have about 1 million dollars in my bank account.
It may sound like I'm putting the cart before the horse,...
...but I will work really hard to gather wealth.
To make my short - term goals more practical, and real,...
...I should get started now.